then I understand that this took a long  time for you to write yeah I think it  was about like a seven year seven and a  half by this point year process and many  of those years were rising and trying to  figure out what I wanted this to be and  in those early days it was something a  bit more conventionally structured  that's where I needed to begin to get a  handle on what it was and then using my  own experiences and allowing myself to  be inspired by photographs by  by my own relationships eventually that  process became impossible to  remove from the script it kind of found  its way in when I finally wrote that  even when I considered whether  the the framing device of the Rave the  elements of memory were strictly  necessary to it it became clear that  they were because without them there  there was no film I had no idea what it  was